le front ukrainien maintenant un coup de
téléphone très attendue aujourd'hui
américain et russe se sont échangé à
distance se parler en direct les chefs
de diplomatie anthony blinken et sergueï
lavrov se sont donné rendez-vous le ton
de l'entretien a déjà été donnée hier
dans l'enceinte du conseil de sécurité à
new york russes et américains n'ont fait
que s'invectiver comme le résume tout de
suite notre correspondant emmanuel
saint-martin
il sans grande surprise c'est une
réunion du conseil de sécurité qui a
tourné au bras de fer entre russes et
américains avec un ambassadeur russe
vassili néo nazis qui est venu avec la
ferme intention de dénoncer ce qu'ils
considèrent comme une hystérie
américaine en parlant de mensonges de la
part des américains il a regardé son
homologue l'ambassadrice linda thomass
greenfield en disant c'est un peu comme
si vous appeliez de vos voeux finalement
cette invasion que vous décrivez qui
simplement dans votre imagination donc
en face évidemment l'ambassadrice
américaine lynne date masse greenfield
elle au contraire a dit que c'est 100
mille troupe qui serait massé qui sont
massés à l'extérieur des frontières
craignait n'est bien représente une real
réelle menace pour la sécurité
internationale qu'il fallait à tout prix
choisir le chemin de la diplomatie c'est
ce qu'elle a répété comme le font les
américains tout en laissant elle aussi
plané évidemment la menace des sanctions
contre la russie et ses alliés sur ce
dossier mais l'essentiel sans doute pour
les américains ça aura été de sonner
l'alarmé à lherm la halle art sur la
scène internationale en disant linda
linda daumas greenfield que finalement
si cette invasion russe de l'ukraine se
produit si un mouvement de troupes en
ukraine de la part des russes eh bien
personne ne pourra dire qu'il n'a été
prévenu